vous aurez de nombreuses possibilités ce
soir pour choisir le lieu où vous
pourrez voir le match alors à saint
germain en les autres que le soubise
le pub anglais le bit à rennes 2
retransmettra l'événement
l'établissement est limitée à 40
personnes à l'intérieur il vaut donc
mieux arriver tôt 1 ce soir pour avoir
une place comme celle amnesia d'ailleurs
ce bar brasserie prévoit quand même
trois téléviseurs en terrasse et 4 à
l'intérieur et en ce qui concerne les
habitants de saint quentin en yvelines
est ce que eux aussi pourront avoir le
droit à des retransmissions
bien sûr comme au bar o dan pâti à
voisins le bretonneux
le gérant est prêt à accueillir une
centaine de personnes et a même prévu
une petite animation pour tous les
matchs de l'équipe de france à la mi
temps
donc on a un champion de france
freestyle rookie donc qui viendra faire
des démonstrations durant tous les
matches de l'équipe de france j'espère
jusqu'à là jusqu'à la finale donc ça va
être ça va être sympa alors que nous on
va attraper là c'est une fan zone qui
est proposé c'est ça au stade sans sac
les trappistes pourront suivre sur écran
géant les matches des bleus 522
personnes maximum sont attendus
obligation d'être assis et masqués pour
ce match la femme zone est déjà complet
tant à l'heure où je vous parle
mais elle devrait peut-être être re
proposer pour les autres matches à venir
pour les bleus du gros jonc aussi se
doit du côté de poissy oui la ville de
poissy retransmettra haut sur écran
géant les trois matches de poule de
l'équipe de france au forum
armand peugeot la capacité est limitée à
550 spectateurs maximum pour bien sûr
respecter l'âge aux sanitaires
aucune réservation ne sera ne sera prise
en tout cas et premier arrivé premier
servi
il y aura aussi une exposition
artistique qui sera proposé aux pistes
eux oui sur la place de la république
les passants pourront apercevoir un
ensemble de 16 panneaux sur les thèmes
grand monsieur du football comme vous
pouvez le voir sur ces images une
dizaine de portraits comme karim benzema
ngolo kanté ou encore olivier giroud
tous ont signé de l'artiste parisien
bobby dollars et on précise d'ailleurs
ans célia que pour rappel ces lieux
seront fermés à partir de 23h à l'heure
du couvre feu